in the previous episode sir what are you
alright oh yeah after the car thing
no I'm yah so I the way you never told
me your name
Ethan be careful Ethan fine I'll be
careful
and
are you prepared to suffer to say you're
like oh come to the old power plant
alright
all right we go I don't know that one my
name is Bearpaw welcome back to another
episode of heavy rain
we're here with Easton we're gonna go on
trial number three to save our son we're
at a factory I think some sort of factor
food I really don't like this trial it
freaks the [ __ ] out of me
but let's do it anyway this was also the
first trial I ever failed and I think I
say this every time and I think that's
really what makes this game awesome is
that even if you fail no if you fail the
game continues so you really really
don't want to fail if you want the
rights ending I don't know ah [ __ ] it
doesn't work we need to find another and
I don't know it makes you feel for the
game in a lot different way than you
would normally play a story in my
opinion so that this is going to be
wonderful
on the following glorious I forgot
pies my eyes you could see my nipples
right now I think she liked it does like
my nipples oh oh no I hate thee I
started saved I'm gonna [ __ ] fail at
this mission come on heads just I guess
our one and are two mixed up see
I'm so far this is our tune
all right oh wow oh my finger Oh mang I
don't worry about it we gotta save our
son a little finger blood doesn't hurt
anybody except that one who died from a
finger blood don't worry about him
it's not me all right
where are we it's gotta be an entrance
well I love the camera angles bro bro
well oh there's a butterfly there that's
so regatta we were looking for so let's
go over that shall we
come on Nathan we don't got all day
high voltage acting fantastic all right
let the trials begin Oh creepy
I'm Xing I'm acting like crazy
why do we got in his side hopefully not
a jump-scare
a pair of matches [ __ ] I remember
unfortunately you gotta go
inside of this [ __ ] [ __ ] spookiest
[ __ ] ah
alright let's go alright I think I had
this figured out this is that a nice ass
bra
I know going back mr. Ethan you went in
there you know what the costs were all
right let's get the lighter going let's
see what it is I should never have got
into come on hype it sure why we got
this it's not suicide this is the
[ __ ] pipe people go here all the time
not all the time but sometime I have a
bad feeling
where's this pipe go broken glass
glass broken glass sharp as a razor
impossible to go back I'm gonna have to
crawl through it slowly so I don't turn
my arms did you just take off your
jacket and put it around your arms or
just do like this to shove them away or
just [ __ ] out Wow Wow
all right I think it's a lek here I hope
I remember I got lost the last time Baba
the match flame indicates where the
fresh okay all I have to do is follow
the wind okay was the right then [ __ ] it
no don't do it again please
it did again the match flame it
indicates where is it
all right fine let's go left I mean
right ow
oh no it hurts me I gotta go slow
come on Ethan you can do it I love you
Ethan okay I don't love you sorry I lied
about them haha
all right which way a lefty I left it is
I think this is I hope this is come on
Ethan it's all their broken glass your
little spicy okay it probably hurts a
lot but hey
my vision is getting blurry easy dog
I've got to move slowly don't fade on me
bro this is the place where I'll get a
lot it's just like a 3-way segment and
table we got to do it for my son it
turns to the left let's do some
inspirational thoughts the pain I'm
bleeding all over my skin's torn to
pieces
don't worry about it's this blood and
skin it's disgusting
bro all right what else do you got to
say
keep it together mine ate them on stupid
[ __ ] of a [ __ ] pipe and Charlie's
gonna die because of me can't stand you
names come on can't take it much and you
can do it we're always there
I've got to get out of here there's got
to be a while yeah I was the idea wasn't
it
come on brah which way left
I mean right [ __ ] it I suck at
remembering which ones which oh there it
is come on in then one steps for date
then Mon step for your [ __ ] wife and
one step for John and one step for
j-john Cavalli all of them face don't
face don't think we came so far you
don't need to light your magic now we
did it for us the bad thing this is only
the beginning oh [ __ ] oh shed
alright get up get up get up
alright let's go
why has it taped all right
I guess I don't really have any choice I
wouldn't go down there I would be so
scared I mean I would do it for Stefan
ah come on get down there
are you going or what glad to release
so slow these cries even electricity
oh [ __ ] a maze of electricity
ah do not touch it - and they already
got my figure [ __ ]
alright let's just do it nope it's
getting let's do it
coward so you can fail if you go through
that thing
god damn it not a coward doing this for
Sun sunny soon all right
I could never do these it's a lot more
difficult than you like flying
good job eat then we got the first one
brofist yes alright so this one
I don't have anymore fingers I don't
have any more peg I know yes all this
[ __ ] it's really is weirdest pop like
all right good job Ethan now the real
tricky part starts right you're not
going that way now
which day which button is that
all right oh [ __ ] this is not good eyes
let's give him some thoughts analyze
better have a good look at each one of
those condensers if I choose the right
route I'll have a better chance of
coming through this in one piece
ah [ __ ] it
that's not gonna work all right yeah
this is the one this is one
come on Ethan
it really doesn't look that safe I don't
have that many fingers yes but it's got
thing but I did it
alright now what we got a look at them
oh my god
oh my god haha yes yes hahaha I never
done this before
oh thank god mmm roofer dirt dirt murder
oh he's almost rounding Rosevelt no roll
12th Street no that's what I got from
that
come on you can save your son
daddy brows we get it are you proud of
me but no
Madison Madison Madison Madison Madison
Madison met yet nailed it
I want to pick at her eyebrows oh when I
pick her her eyebrows I want to pick up
lick up like a blinker on bright I'm
gonna pick up a brat let's play a little
more because I probably took a lot of
time and I'm probably going to add it a
little bit of that so we can lick her
face girl - a time
I start a son
tell us did you get her ass wouldn't be
bad if it thought it would be good
actually ma'am
wouldn't it be funny if it doesn't rain
oh no a that oh my god I gotta do
something
all right so patches [ __ ] up for even
like his nipples I'm relating that's a
bad sign
horrible sign [ __ ]
how does that help seriously medicine
what are you doing
what the [ __ ]
so there can be a romance between these
two characters I like to see them
together so yeah spoilers for nipple
why do you breasts think Ethan Ethan can
you hear me
what is her thoughts I have to help him
calm down girl
there must be something I can do that
girl explanation oh my god
what happened to him what do we did the
last time just [ __ ] going to the No
the bathroom that worked last time I
[ __ ] it let's investigate his box to
sniff around yes
origami figures don't touch that is he
doing with them re gambit figure what is
I don't want my damn origami figure I
love you love origami figure ah
so son and it opened up my eyes that's
all would sign can't [ __ ] find the
bandages no no no no no all right let's
cuddle em
he's burning hot you've got a hell of a
fever all right for our youth then you
could buy if you continues like this are
those burn marks on your chest
oh hello ah your clothes off to
disinfect the urns okay Shira disinfect
yards wounds I know what she's trying to
do oldest trick in the bag bro
it's nipples what's pretty good [ __ ]
nipple that nipple is never gonna see
nipple light again but at least it will
go to nipple heaven arms oh you do dad
became EEMA I need to disinfect your
wounds
those are serious burn this is [ __ ]
touch then I don't know if I can do
anything for you um let's go to the
bathroom and take a pee a people Bupa
paper Papa Papa Papa all right
get those and those and those and those
and those and
I'm no doctor but I don't touch there
bro
all right first we got a disinfectant
dr. Pierce just signing in all right I'd
see what problem it
it's just disinfect a pooper gentle
gently jet oh that's not affected not
terribly dr. burns whoops
it's season four his arms gentle gentle
blah blah blah hey stop playing sorry
you complain one more time I'll [ __ ]
camp site lapa lapa ah hi sorry I'll go
easier and think this is a take forever
laughs a flower pot only one of the arms
because you know my who needs two arms
yeah that's helping your wounds are
disinfected all right let's get some
ointment chicks love pointment
get a lot of that point man in there
disgust me I hate pointment I think it's
the most disgusting thing ever I can't
even put on Sun Tan scream just [ __ ]
yeah Sam gets the puck sorry I'll take
it easy okay I ain't even [ __ ] think
hey sorry I'll take it easy he said that
and it didn't really work did it
geez I'm not sure I'm helping him I
better stop
hey are they gonna talk
poor guy she crying
I press I'm gonna intercept so here by
like a barrel if you enjoyed subscribe
to become a bro today and I'll see you
next episode
Thank You Brad
you